mois de novembre il n'y aura plus de
mission russe de représentation auprès
de l'otan ni de représentation de l'otan
à moscou suspension qui vient d'être
annoncé par le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères pour plus de détails
on retrouve notre correspondant à moscou
entraîne les roues
la réponse de moscou n'aura tarder que
quelques jours après le renvoi de huit
membres de la mission de représentation
russe auprès de l'otan les autorités ont
frappé fort la russie a décidé de ne
plus se voiler la face et d'arrêter je
cite de prétendre que de meilleures
relations avec l'alliance atlantique
était possible dans un avenir proche
nous avons pris les décisions suivantes
en raison des démarche délibérée de la
part de l'otan nous ne disposons pas des
conditions adéquates pour mener des
activités diplomatiques élémentaire et
en réponse aux actions de l'otan nous
suspendons le travail de notre mission
permanente auprès de l'otan y compris le
travail de représentant militaire en
chef probablement à partir du 1er
novembre ou peut-être que cela prendra
encore quelques jours
deuxièmement nous suspendons les
activités de la mission de liaison
militaire de l'otan à moscou
l'accréditation de ses employés sera
révoqué à partir du 1er novembre 2021 et
troisièmement les activités du bureau
d'information de l'otan à moscou qui a
été créé auprès de l'ambassade du
royaume de belgique prenne fin
les autorités russes voient en effet une
contradiction entre d'un côté les
déclarations des représentants de l'otan
qui appelle à une normalisation des
relations avec la russie et de l'autre
leurs actions cette mission
d'observateurs de la russie auprès de
l'otan avait pour objectif de coopérer
sur certains dossiers et ce malgré les
tensions entre les deux entités la
mission en question cessera donc ses
activités à partir du 1er novembre
prochain dorénavant pour contacter
moscou l'otan devra passer par
l'ambassade de russie en belgique